I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
do you believe dragons ever existed I
mean not unless there's fossilized proof
do you think that the medicine that
there do you really live there were
dinosaurs yeah I'm not a flat earther
well I heard that they might not
maybe the bones weren't even put
together right maybe dinosaurs are just
sort of like kind of made up I want to
lean into I'll lead into probably myself
but answer is true yeah yeah there is
some law for that somebody made me dice
recently as a present that were made of
like the head like mammoth tusks in them
hmm and people went crazy online Oh
Maddie how dare you promoting the murder
victim of mammoths it's like I said I
just had a thousand years ago the dead
they're gone like it's a rock like you
can't
I'm not telling people to go kill me do
you realize mammoths they they died out
like 20,000 years ago yeah sure yeah
yeah some people don't even think earth
was around 20,000 years ago so there's
also that yeah poor people so do I a
little warming isn't real either mm-hmm
well you know a flat earth is an
interesting thing you brought up I would
say that it's probably more likely I
don't think it I think it's round I do
but I think it's probably more likely
than flat earth that it's a holographic
universe okay so are we talking so we're
like mentally just like answer Donna hey
we're kind of out filling stellar we're
like our mind is being populated by what
we've learned and experienced and just
fills it all in and it's everything in
the world can be broken down to zeros
and ones what's this what's this we are
energy if you condensed all if you
content all humans on earth down to
actual matter
it's about size of an apple I ask Neil
deGrasse Tyson like the 21 grams type of
thing
I don't know what's like when they say
when people die mm-hmm well that's all
this is well no they say that they lose
21 grams of weight that's it this is
like a thing that they've measured they
say that the soul weighs 21 grams Oh
interesting so there you go there's your
so it's the energy yeah that it goes
somewhere so the question is like are we
all just transmitting data back to a
cloud those are some kind of mothership
so far off of this holographic universe
idea well there was there's a great cool
well like there was a Playboy magazine
interview with with oh my god why my
eyes watched my brains in there yeah so
Kubrick did this anyone and fascinating
guy in he argon he was talking about
like the greatest fear in life is that
that you know if there is a god it
doesn't it doesn't care that it's
indifferent everybody wants to believe
that God's sitting next to you and your
convertible on that sunny day driving in
the PCH and you know people want to
believe that it's not there when
children are dying in third-world
countries so there's this big argument
as to you know if got everything or got
nothing in this guy got care and so
Kubrick had this big huge he kind of
like brilliantly pontificated about this
idea that it doesn't care its impartial
and that's the greatest fear so it's
like one chess game I had no purpose it
just doesn't it doesn't care like it's
just doesn't care if you live like
people are gonna get diseases people are
gonna die people thick random shits
gonna happen yeah and and it's just it's
all part of this so then where does that
put you in terms of you know it's like
Stephen Hawking Stephen Hawking his
entire life was a search for gone
basically and he died and said it
doesn't exist and that's I'm not sure
you know like it was right or was it
just this is a guy who was stricken with
something so difficult and lived the
most difficult life out of anybody I
could ever possibly imagine
and maybe this was a personal thing that
like if this could happen to mean I had
to live like this the campaign
it can't be it can't be why would it do
that cheer up religious like I was an
altar boy
I love till sixth grade yeah that go I
went to public school the next year and
I told my mom I said I have to dress
different cuz I'm going to public school
now yeah so you need to take me to the
mall and she did and I said I need a
Guns and Roses team I need a skid row
you really battled against the altar boy
outfit but I'll tell you this I are the
khakis and the vest yeah first day of
seventh grade skid-row shirt like the
hot girls are outside smoking cigarettes
the bad girls they smoke in seventh
grade oh yeah yeah they're cool smoking
cigarettes outside of high school I walk
by McFly Skid Row's t-shirt and like the
the hottest girl out of the group was
like nice shirt and I was like would
your parents think about that I think
your mom stuff yeah she was I mean they
didn't they just wanted you to be happy
yeah but I think I think there was
definitely a seed planted from that that
connects to you know heavy metal street
wear cuz it's like you know there's
there's there's a group of people out
there who are pretty cool who like that
aesthetic and I want to take it back to
smoking outside the high school people
and they're not yeah murderers not fun I
mean look you know I don't really talk
to a lot of those people today because
they gotten a lot of trouble as adults
but you know at the time it was fun and
I think there's a you know there's a
there's a youth there's a vitality to
that that kind of aesthetic you know
that that I remember so well from the
early and mid 80s like it was fun you
know Danzig and Ozzy and Metallica like
all that stuff was fun and I had this
like fun energy to it and that's what
you know a lot of the line tries the
capture
[Music]